hey what's going on its bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
my October October 2nd oh my god get out
you [ __ ] Barracuda dude it's the
[ __ ] fall it's officially the fall
isn't it lovely honda leaves turning
different colors and falling off the
trees and crunching under your feet
halloween comes and then thanksgiving
and it'll be good 75 80 degrees with
whatever but the oceans rising but
whatever is going very interesting it's
gonna be very interesting false i feel
coming up oh do you feel it bill
was this your own idea did you stick
your head out the window and assess it
or did you listen to a bunch of [ __ ] on
TV alright you got me you got me but it
is the fall the fall is one of my
favorite seasons what I loved about the
fall was the beginning of the school
year and I absolutely loved school I
just when I was a child I just I craved
knowledge I don't know what it was I of
course the other kids wanted to go
outside and play and engage in contests
of sport but not me
now I just wanted to curl up in the
corner just couldn't just my mother just
couldn't get me enough books I know I
was obviously I was obviously a non
truth now that was true what I liked
about the fall was I got new clothes for
school you know which back then was you
got your hand-me-downs from your brother
and you got a new pair of sneakers
alright and they were new until that
first time it [ __ ] rained or
something happened and then they would
just you know that was it and those were
your sneakers for a year you wore
sneakers for a year your mother bought
him like a half size or a full size too
big dependent we know she was trying to
gauge you know when your balls were
gonna drop too considering how big your
feet we're gonna be right there's one of
those yeah one of those things back then
there was like nine grades all in one
class now [ __ ] with you
I like the new sneakers and the new
clothes and whatever hand-me-down [ __ ]
that I got from my older brother and
and then it was football and then also
it was starting to get cold so I didn't
have to deal with anymore
dude look out white your [ __ ] legs
are I didn't have to deal with that with
the summer I didn't feel was sunburns I
liked it it was more of a [ __ ] winter
guy but other than that everything else
sucked I [ __ ] knock out 180 days of
school to go can you believe it used to
think that that was hard and he actually
used to [ __ ] up in school if you like me
I was at back it's just like why did I
just come home why not just pay
attention come home and just do my
homework I could have gone to like a
really good college like and to me a
good college is it has it has a sports
program that I can follow its Division
one and you know they battle for [ __ ]
at least to win their conference you
know what I mean I don't [ __ ] I don't
know I don't [ __ ] like these College
you should go to where everybody is I
don't know what it is like to take
Vanderbilt in the SEC by the way who
played a hell of a [ __ ] game this
weekend right scared the [ __ ] out of
Florida I always thought that you know I
always I always assumed that that school
sucked because their football team was
no good for so long now they're actually
halfway decent but I judge schools by
how good their sports program is and you
know there's a lot of people on real
sports so one of those shows that you
know everybody wears suits and for some
reason they have a pen but they're never
really writing you know those shows that
take it really seriously and they little
that's a little the educational system
that people judge a school by their
sports programs well no this you're
[ __ ] pencil-pushing nerd there would
be no campus without sports okay goes
right back into the school doesn't it
God knows it's not paying the players
all right and that's why when you go to
the University of Michigan it's its own
[ __ ] City it's not because of the
science department well the engineers
that know how to build the buildings
it's because a big blue down the [ __ ]
Street
pullin a pullin one hundred four hundred
five hundred ten thousand people a
goddamn game that's what pays for it you
know even if it's not all that money the
level of attention and that makes people
all around the world you know know that
song hail to the victors valiant hail to
the victors [ __ ] get on a raft get
over here and go to that school right is
that how it goes I don't know I think
what the [ __ ] was I talking about why I
like the fall yeah I just what a [ __ ]
did I study so [ __ ] stoop I can't
believe I can't imagine if I actually
understood calculus what my fun my world
would be like right now I just took the
time to [ __ ] I mean it's like they just
dumped it all on you the first day I
forget when I stopped paying attention
somewhere around seventh grade I just
was like I just I'm just not into this
oh my god I could have studied and then
I could do one of those extracurricular
things and got like a scholarship you
know participated in a bunch of other
[ __ ] then I would have that all fleshed
out I see you're on the debating team
you're on the swimming team and all that
[ __ ] remember those [ __ ] kids the kid
next to yous Locker was like neat you
know and it wasn't all dented and [ __ ]
[ __ ] always had his homework more
like sweaters you know you just be
looking at him like kind of find it [ __ ]
does this person it's like my age and
they have their [ __ ] that together I
always had a thousand papers falling out
of my [ __ ] that just was a mess and
every year I'd be like hey this is year
I'm gonna study I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
not drawing all over my books I'm gonna
pay attention I'm gonna try to get all
A's and beast that's out that's all I
wanted to do and I just I
couldn't do it I put up a good fight
through about I get to about September
10th then I get like that first [ __ ]
see see see see what's that what's that
a reference to speaking moving look
movie lines see see see is it summer
rentals or summer school that was the
guy who's been on TV for 40 years but
never does interview so people kind of
Mark Harmon is that his name who's that
guy like chainsaw some [ __ ] and of
course it made the Latino girl pregnant
cuz you could still do that back then
can't do that now you get called out on
they would never do that now now they
would make the white guy pregnant to
show that they're progressive that's how
it would work
you don't mean there's nothing wrong
with having a Latino woman be pregnant
but when she's the only Latino in the
[ __ ] movie that's when it becomes a
problem also she's going to summer
school and she's knocked up and she's
dressed like [ __ ] zebra man in heavy
metal parking lot do you know I had
never seen that I thought that was an
entire [ __ ] movie nice for years I
was like I gotta get around to watching
heavy metal parking lot I never [ __ ]
saw it and finally somebody referenced
it again oh I know why Dean Del Rey from
the let there be talk all things comedy
network podcast he sent me a link and
one of the one of Judas Priest's
guitarists who that was KK downing and
Glenn Tipton his glenn tipton he bought
I hope I'm saying his name right
he bought a [ __ ] Porsche in 1985 or
86 he went to the factory when he was on
tour and that's back when they made him
hate that was hand-built none of this
robot [ __ ] none of this outsourcing it
to [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] they do it
now they were hand-built okay by the
same people that brought you audiotape
in World War one and World War two
all right it was [ __ ] they were hand
[ __ ] bill
it's right the same people that brought
you
Oktoberfest and the Holocaust you know I
mean they're all over the map over there
that's why Germany is still such a scary
country it's like what's gonna happen
over here oh we all gonna get drink
beers and get shit-faced or are you guys
gonna try to take over the world again
you know that's what's on there Weather
Channel as they monitor all the psychos
over there what are they what is the
general population planning right now or
possibly a small group of really
motivated people within boys land so
anyways I had never seen heavy metal
parking lot I thought it was a full
movie so I sit down to watch it
right out of the gate I love it because
the concerts at the cap Center and
that's where I used to watch the you
know whatever the Bruins used to play
when they've gone out and played the
Capitals they had rod Lang way who
looked like my math teacher back in the
day man my math teacher was a dead
[ __ ] ringer I flunked his class two
[ __ ] years in a row it was two
summers I'll never get back actually my
senior year I didn't [ __ ] go to
summer schools like but what's the point
I can't get into a school that has a
good foot you know football program a
basketball program I don't know sports
here so [ __ ] it anyways what the [ __ ] am
I talking about you know so I'm watching
this thing so they had the cap Center
which I never really saw what it looked
like because they never really showed
the outside that I can remember there
just be the Broads that I cap Center
Barry Petersen leading the league with
40 some goals that great year he had
then we traded him I believe so I go to
watch this [ __ ] thing and I gotta be
honest with you like the memories that
came flying back first of all my first
concert ever was Judas Priest with Doc
and opening-up of course it was Dakin
they [ __ ] open for everybody they
opened for everybody in Tesla open for
[ __ ] and Cinderella opened for
[ __ ] everybody
that was my first on the turbo lover
tour right and I guess I found out all
these years later that that Judas Priest
guy glenn tipton or whatever bought a
[ __ ] Porsche that was a turbo and he
loved it so much that he's [ __ ] you
know was inspired to write a song and
then rob halford took it in whatever
direction he wanted to take it it you
know though we remember this song I'm
your turbo lover make no sense right you
won't see me something but you feel me
[Music]
like crazy music right I saw them on
that tour so anyway so I watched that a
heavy metal parking lot and I thought it
was [ __ ] great that's exactly I mean
whoever [ __ ] film that I know I'm way
way way past the hole everybody knows it
by now whoever filmed that thing thank
you so much for filming that I renewed
the first time I ever saw anybody do
blow I went to an ac/dc concert I
remember I pull up my big stupid red
[ __ ] hair right you know and I can't
grow it long my hair just grew out so I
was like I missed it man I should have
come up in the 70s I would have been
fine we've been rocking that Bernie from
room 222 but you know everybody kind of
had their [ __ ] you know I don't know
what the [ __ ] it was in the 80s wasn't
short but it wasn't long it was bright
before the mullets feathered everything
was feathered Farrah Fawcett was so hot
even the guys trying to have their hair
like hers right that's what was going on
and me I was just like you know I was a
man without us but without a [ __ ]
country so I would pull up you know not
a whisker on my face I [ __ ] pull up
and my stupid [ __ ] looking like I
swear to God looking like a giant Opie
Taylor and and I was totally into the
music but I I just look like a [ __ ]
freak you know I should have grown my I
go I actually couldn't grow my hair said
should at least go on the Malakai route
and just been drunk enough and just got
out of the car and screamed Outlander
and then everybody will left me own
alone I remember I
pulled up to the a the ac/dc tag and
this [ __ ] guy was doing blow I think
he had a Toyota pickup truck rusted out
of course back then everything [ __ ]
rusted out especially the Toyota honking
honks of [ __ ] but the engines would
never die right you'd be put driving
down the street you could literally see
the [ __ ] engine still working so this
guy gets out of the car and I'm like
looking at him like I know we like the
same kind of music but we are not the
same person I remember he was [ __ ]
yeah there's blond hair look like he cut
his own hair it was like something like
a fucked-up pageboy haircut and like a
perm all at the same time and like he
turned around to do the line and then
[ __ ] came right up to my window as I
pulled up looking like a [ __ ] I got
it no I felt like I was one of those
zoos where the animals aren't in a cage
you know he just came up and he was like
good and I was kind of lame at 40 I was
with somebody else I think that we were
listening to who made who would a very
respectable volume yeah that was a who
made who won and loudness opened up a
Japanese heavy metal band I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about here
let's let's let's get into the podcast
I'm just sort of meandering here why
don't we talk a little bit and it felt
football wait look we got to talk
college first all right so what I
watched I watched I watched Texas Tech
against Oklahoma State what a [ __ ]
great game that was and what an ad out
there in Lubbock Texas I got to go to a
Texas Tech game man so I was actually
out there I was looking up theaters to
see if they had a little theater I could
play maybe next year or whatever during
football season you know anybody can go
to Dallas right I've already been to
Texas A&M and I've been to the Texas
Longhorns the next big program is Texas
Tech right of course they'll give you
[ __ ] at Baylor SMU they never recovered
from the [ __ ] death penalty but what
else they got out there I don't think
that's it so I was rooting for Texas
Tech because I just just because they
were the underdog but was such a [ __ ]
great game
and I was flipping back and forth you
know my adopted college team LSU [ __ ]
Tigers you know we lost again but you
know we lost to the Trojans so that's
okay you know
that's how I say it to people you know
we lost this week to the Trojans
I thought USC lost to all they did I was
talking about the troy trojans from the
very formidable Sun Belt Conference I
was embarrassed as a new LSU fan I
became an LSU fan about nine years ago
and as a adopted team to see all those
[ __ ] people leave the [ __ ] Stadium
emptied out with eight minutes to go all
right granted they needed three scores
but uh I I didn't like that at all
I hate seeing that and then obvious at
that point just rooting that they came
back and won just so all those [ __ ]
[ __ ] would have to lie on Monday and
say that they they were part of the 40
people that still stuck around but I'm
trying to think what was worse watching
LSU to lose to Troy or the troy trojans
helmets you know you know everything has
to look like [ __ ] I don't know you
know that you know that just all that
awful candy at movie theaters like they
only sell it at movie theaters whatever
those [ __ ] things are I don't mean
gummy bears do you have a good friend of
mine that loves gummy bears guy friend
it's just I don't know it just it almost
[ __ ] up our friendship you know like
Warner when we kind of bug at me
whatever I just kind of think everyone
Celeste gets [ __ ] guy likes gummi
bears I'll do it I love going to movies
you know I [ __ ] love going to movies
I take my kids you know get a box of
gummy bears gummy bears yeah the [ __ ]
Oregon Ducks all right those green and
yellow [ __ ] they [ __ ] it up for
everybody they were the first ones to
put the disco ball in their head and now
everybody's doing it I'm calling it
right now those [ __ ] things are gonna
look they're gonna look [ __ ]
ridiculous
in years to come people will be like
what enough is that electric is that
thing like plugged in or some [ __ ]
some of them are cool I guess I don't
know what but I love how the MLB this
year they went back to the like they
went to like this non gloss matte color
on the batting helmets they look [ __ ]
mean as hell man mean is hell man so
anyways that's what the [ __ ] I watched
and then I watched pro football today
Oh Jay Jay's the New England Patriots
with their second loss of the year part
of me and joys that they lost twice
because it keeps all the [ __ ] pray be
nice to have a nice [ __ ] anticipation
free season you know and when you're 2 &
2 God knows nobody's [ __ ] looking at
you now how about that defense huh the
[ __ ] I'll tell you okay right now if you
want to score 30 points you got to go to
New England I'm trying to I should look
this up like we gave up I think we gave
up 75 points in the first two games and
then we added another 30 today is that
what happened let's look at the Patriots
here let's look at the sad sad tale and
I can't figure out what the [ __ ] is
going on I mean how many yards have we
given up this year on just like blown
coverages that [ __ ] fake screen pass
like the entire defense on that side
bites on it you know if we look at our
corners and our safeties it's still
Butler Chung McCrory those guys have
been playing together for years I don't
know how long we've had the Gilmore guy
but I like that guy that guy hits hard
he knocked somebody out of the game yet
another good hit you had a [ __ ]
hands to the face and then a brutal one
but we shouldn't have been in that
situation to begin with but our offense
is fine
I mean course I would love if our
offensive line could give him a little
Brady a little more time he's definitely
taking too many hits but we're still
scoring points but our defense Jesus
Christ not really stopping the run not
really getting pressure on the
quarterback
blown [ __ ] coverages but I just feel
like the blown coverages that's
something that you know Matt Patricia
can work on right
you can get those guys like three or
four them it's just like you guys want
to [ __ ] Super Bowl last year I'm not
I don't know all the Patriots so I don't
know when Gilmore get on the [ __ ]
team all right let's look at Patriots
here
Patriots calm I should have gone
scheduled right is that what I should
have done this is gonna take for [ __ ]
ever
Patriots schedule alright here we go
Patriots schedule they're gonna go
download this schedule what okay so we
let up 42 points the first week then we
were on the road only let up 20 then we
let up 33 and we let up 33 again those
were all it [ __ ] up no two of those
were home three of those weren't home
jesus [ __ ] christ
alright 33 36 42 I think I don't know I
have just to glance at those numbers
wait 33 33 42 20 thank God for the 20
all right 42 and 20 is 60 - so that's 31
so we're averaging like [ __ ] I don't
know 30 I guess 32 points a [ __ ] game
yeah by the way my [ __ ] football pick
came in I called it the [ __ ] Giants
get in three against Tampa Bay dude I
told you granted the Giants didn't
[ __ ] win but they only lost by two
and as a patriot fan I hate that the
Giants are owned for more so than I hate
the fact that we're two and two because
I wanted to play the Giants again in the
Superbowl to [ __ ] beat those bastards
one time well we got nothing to lose the
Giants got everything to lose they got
[ __ ] talking rights right now you just
got to say hey you guys [ __ ] Onis
right by the way somebody tweeted like
to do it was why you guys even [ __ ]
beat us I went to a home game oh no way
game I'm sorry Giants we [ __ ] beat
you I don't know the last time we played
you in the regular season in your
[ __ ] house you [ __ ] it's [ __ ] guys
bragging about preseason games it's like
dude you won two Super Bowls that's all
you give a [ __ ] about
so anyways that's my one pick so now I'm
gonna make another pick on Thursday all
right Abby
every Thursday I'm gonna do my NFL pick
of the week now what's is what you have
to think you're a [ __ ] degenerate
gambler you know good and goddamn well I
have just as much chance with the
information that I'm using of picking a
winner as a housewife who doesn't watch
a game okay
so this first week I'm not gonna say was
dumb luck I was going on [ __ ] how
many points the Giants scored against
the Eagles I know they scored him late
and then Eli Manning who's ripped my
heart out twice showed it to me and then
very politely ate it and did get any
blood in his Dockers right I was like
there's no [ __ ] way that these guys I
thought that they want to come away with
the win I did Buccaneers look great god
bless him by the way who the [ __ ] is
this Ron Funches guy on the on the on
Carolina [ __ ] Panthers guy was
killing us all day long I was I don't
pray for injuries but when his leg
cramped up I was like thank God then he
came back out again caught another first
down
thank you get that [ __ ] guy out of
here so anyways that's what I was basing
it on so I'm gonna pick another one
Thursday and then you the degenerate
gambler you got to be wondering we'll
all freckles
will he get lucky two weeks in a row cuz
now I'm in your head cuz I won last week
this is like playing roulette like going
right the last time was black is it
gonna be another black or is gonna be a
red do I sit out this week see if it
goes to blacks in a row then I know it's
gonna be red alright
no it was red this week I'm a [ __ ]
goddamn ginger all right
remember that guy [ __ ] who didn't pay
his taxes always been on black always
been on red I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say that might be the Photoshop of
this week of that's too [ __ ] easy
right that's a movie poster right there
always bet on red I don't know who's
playing next week so how about those
[ __ ] LA Rams
not your same old Rams [ __ ] winning
then win and beat the Dallas [ __ ]
Cowboys Jesus Christ they're gonna have
their [ __ ] heads in a noose out there
all right well let's get down to it Oh
Billy [ __ ] boos back is back I fell
off the wagon I couldn't do it I'm
[ __ ] with you I'm still on the
[ __ ] wagon I went to Vegas and I
passed that test I was at the the Monte
Carlo not the race the [ __ ] casino
stayed over at the MGM Grand because
they're doing some construction I guess
on the Montecarlo so they had me across
the street and oh my god what a [ __ ] oh
there's there's no better people
watching than when you go to Vegas holy
[ __ ] I went down to the pool yes I went
down to the pool I was working with Bart
Nick he's an Italian guy he actually has
pigment so he want to go down the pools
I got [ __ ] I'm not gonna stay in the
room the whole time so I go down to the
goddamn pool dude and it was like right
as the Sun had already started to go
down it was on the other side of the
casino so it really wasn't any Sun on
the water so there was maybe a five or
six young people there and everybody
else was my generation or older and holy
[ __ ] I know this is a hacky topic I know
this is but thank God I never got a
tattoo thank [ __ ] christ if you saw
these [ __ ] people and they're my age
man 49 years old no shirt on all these
[ __ ] chicks with their ankles
sorority tattoos telling kids what to do
with tattoos you know what I mean and
then that good dude what it kills me
about the tattoo becoming mainstream was
the incredible like lack of research
that most people did their total lack of
respect for the art form and the
complete lack of respect for themselves
to go out and try to actually find
somebody good at it I gotta tell you I
must have seen 500 [ __ ] tattoos on
about a hundred different people down
there at the pool every
just tatted up [ __ ] show
man boobs or just pecs sagging down you
know women you always got to give a pass
because they they have they have to bear
children all right
but guys man there's no [ __ ] reason
you just keep doing the push-ups keep
the chest high and tight what the [ __ ]
are you doing lay off the pizza and the
boots [ __ ] guys just walking around
their saggy chests in the [ __ ] tribal
band the [ __ ] stamps those sorority
ankle tattoo is just [ __ ] horrific I
went down then was just sitting there
just reminded of my own mortality going
like Jesus Christ I really want to
[ __ ] act like I'm above these people
but like you know smartest [ __ ] thing
I that I didn't do was I never got a
tattoo jesus [ __ ] christ
thank Christ I never did it you know I
like they used to be back in the you
know cuz look at me I'm not a tattoo guy
alright tattoo gates got to go back to
badasses you know what I mean guys and
biker gangs or in prison or like chicks
who know how to shoot pool the way the
leather pants right hey I'm out of my
[ __ ] mind
so we went down there and we just looked
at that [ __ ] see a humanity and then
this guy just comes out just screaming
about how he lost 20 grand and he had a
big grin on his face he goes throw me in
the pool like I can't swim maybe I'll
drown
I just lost 20 grand I just lost 20
grand in there and I looked and I was
like that [ __ ] guy doesn't have 20
grand there's no [ __ ] way he's got 20
grand and who [ __ ] walks he's just
acting like he's a big shot right but
maybe he did I have no [ __ ] idea so
then we went over we did the show and
after the show we sat out by this giant
air conditioning duct behind a wall on a
picnic table and smoke cigars it was
great and I didn't participate at all in
the Vegas shenanigans I knew enough when
I walked through the lobby and I saw the
people
the young people's like this is their
time don't be the creepy guy hanging
around ruining it get the [ __ ] out of
here so I went back over to the MGM
walked back and I got back probably
about 12:30 at night and that was that
first wave of women that had had enough
you know two out of three of them I
walking barefoot carrying their
horseshoes right what happens in Vegas
stays in Vegas and they just their dirty
feet just walk into the with a giant
[ __ ] drink and I was glad that I
stayed I did stay out of that and I
didn't booze although I did smoke a
[ __ ] cigar and I kind of did it on an
empty stomach and I got a minute I was a
little [ __ ] nauseous because was this
giant Cuban and the next day we took the
helicopter out and back and on the way
back there was like a 17 to 30 knot wind
depending on what altitude we were until
we really got down low flying over the
15 it got down to like nine knots and we
kind of getting pushed around a little
bit up there and there was a couple
times I was just like oh my god feeling
a little nauseous up here you know
that's not what you want to see from
your pilot asking for a puke bag I mean
the most comforting thing he can say at
that point you know it's all right it's
all right I I drank last night
so anyways but I got to tell you man
flying out there taking the helicopter
and going over the Mojave Desert was it
was [ __ ] incredible the desert is so
it's like beautiful terrifying boiling
hot and freezing all at the same time
it's just [ __ ] I swear to God I don't
know why you know what's something that
people thought we faked the moon landing
that's probably where they went right
the priest went out to the desert you
know what a mountain is oh I don't think
they faked it man I think they can I
think they got up there I have gives a
[ __ ] maybe they didn't there's so much
[ __ ] for me to [ __ ] babble about you
guys watch the Formula One at all huh
anybody see it did anybody she ate it
all what do I have it here
I get to the [ __ ] standings I know
what's-his-face one from Red Bull Red
Bull had two [ __ ] cars and I can now
I always want to say I always [ __ ] up
that guy's name the [ __ ] is his name who
wanted
who won the race today the [ __ ] his
name what is his name max Verstappen
once I think Sebastian Vettel I can't
think for snapping because that V like
my brain can only handle one V word a
minute or the same letter I'm telling
you I don't know what the [ __ ] my deal
is but this is the first race that I saw
with Lewis Hamilton or Valtteri Bottas
in the Mercedes teams one of what either
one of them if they if they're in first
[ __ ] place going into the turn the
Mercedes cars are just too goddamn good
maybe a Ferrari can run him down I've
never [ __ ] seen it but Red Bull this
was that day this was their track they
were amazing
Lewis Hamilton got into [ __ ] the
first it was the first person it came
out in the lead I can't even talk this
[ __ ] podcast I apologize came out of
the first turn in the lead and as far as
mine year and a half of watching this
[ __ ] that means you're gonna win the
race especially if you're in a Mercedes
and for snapping actually came right up
on him and went right around him like it
was nothing and then opened up like an
eight nine second lead on him I have
I've never seen that a Mercedes humbled
like that by Red Bull so congratulations
then Daniel Ricciardo came in third
place and Lewis Hamilton [ __ ] steady
steady Eddy they're still got second
place
he's got 281 [ __ ] points Sebastian
Vettel for whatever [ __ ] reason
Ferrari I don't know what that doing my
daughter had her first cold man so I was
kind of watching her so I missed the
beginning all a sudden Kimi räikkönen
had someone going on with his turbo and
he didn't even [ __ ] drive and
Sebastian Vettel was way in the back so
I'm gonna guess he the [ __ ] up during
the time trials and got some sort of
penalty or they had to switch out a
gearbox there's some [ __ ] that puts you
at the back of the race you're only
allowed to use so many parts so many
engines or something like that
throughout the season so he was all the
way in the back he was able to work
himself all the way up to fourth place
which was really impressive but now he
is be as what does he got he's 34
[ __ ] points I mean I don't think that
they'd make it up after that debacle in
Singapore that absolute [ __ ] Three
Stooges [ __ ] debacle I don't think
that they make it up but it was very
exciting as a new fan of Formula One to
actually see somebody in force first
place and get past actually see a
mercedes-benz in first place and get
past it gave me hope that Formula One
can be more like that the way MotoGP is
all right anyway so let's get to some of
the reads here for the week some of they
actually some of the advertising here
shall we
but puh-puh-puh where is it ah look
who's here ProFlowers oh no wait wait
wait wait
did I cut that off this podcast it just
[ __ ] blows what am i doing today oh
look who's here me undies Dobby undies
biondi's bill can't [ __ ] read to do
me undies B undies my ass is starting to
bleed but thank God I got [ __ ] silk
down by my taint and my balls who
[ __ ] cares if I'm bleeding from the
ah Jesus bill that's not that's just
disgusting you already know me undies
makes the most comfortable underwear in
the world if underwear isn't your thing
man we're excited to announce that me
undies socks are finally here be ready
for work play and everything in between
with the new me undies socks if you
thought your balls felt good if you
thought your balls thanked you every
week wait till you hear what your toes
say me undies socks are now available
now honey socks are spun from premium
materials making their socks the best
you can get for your feet talk about why
me undies is the best underwear and
socks you will ever own well they pay me
to say so and I have a daughter and she
wants to go to college one day and who
knows how long I sell tickets so I might
as well say that these guys have the
best underwear and sucks the undies will
be the most comfortable pair of
underwear and now socks you will ever
own exclusive offer right now me undies
has an exclusive offer Jess
for our listeners and whoever else they
advertise with get 20% off your first
order and free shipping beyond DS is so
sure you will love their underwear and
socks they will give you a hundred
percent I just pictured somebody taking
this you know when someone drives
himself off with the towel and they dry
up their undercarriage just doing that
with the socks during the commercial
going oh my god they feel amazing you
just zoom in and zooming out really
quickly you know to get that effect so
you can't really see the junk you just
see see the sock right and it's so
[ __ ] weird that the millenials buy it
why don't we give Millennials so much
[ __ ] you don't I mean my generation
should they should give like people the
generation older than me [ __ ] for
raising them is that right I don't know
right now me and ease as an exclusive
offer just for our listeners be so sure
you will love their underwear it sucks
they will give you a 100% satisfaction
guarantee simply order a pair if you
don't like it get a full refund this is
a no-brainer 20% off free shipping and
one percent satisfaction guarantee what
are you waiting for
the undies comp size for our beauties
dot-com / / o ProFlowers just in time
for Halloween if you know any of those
people who you know if you know any of
those people who are obsessed with fall
things like pumpkin spice lattes and
scented candles ProFlowers has the
perfect gift it's called the ass vase
you take a [ __ ] long-stem rose now a
long-lasting bouquet and their favorite
fall colors their best-selling cinnamon
cider roses are a great option for a
birthday an anniversary any fall
occasion I'll go with one of the
classics like 100 autumn blooms or a
dozen autumn roses well I don't
understand what do [ __ ] buys flowers in
October it's the end don't they die this
time of year you buy them in the spring
100 autumn balloons well when they
[ __ ] they turn colors because they
can't breathe anymore you can't lose
because no matter which bouquet
okay you send my listeners get 20% off
of any of the ProFlowers unique bouquets
for $29 or more is this way you buy like
that [ __ ] it looks like something
you'd yell through but it's really it
it's made like it's made like a basket
weaving class and there's a bunch of
[ __ ] falling out of it usually a squash
ProFlowers bouquets are guaranteed to
stay fresh for at least seven days or
your money back and you control the
delivery date ProFlowers gives you more
bloom for your buck big beautiful
flowers more stems for your money and
long lasting freshness to get 20% off
all the bouquets for $29 and more go to
ProFlowers and use my code Burpee URR
that's proflowers.com code name BER what
is that [ __ ] thing called let's do a
search here
Thanksgiving horn thing basket squash
see if this gets anything BAM
a cornucopia it's a cornucopia basket
look at that I nailed it
Thanksgiving horn thing basket squash
got me there
alright dollish Dollar Shave Club dude
what you might not know is that Dollar
Shave Club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in the
bathroom a body wash shampoo hair gel
lip balm herpes medicine everything at
the store the crab comb at the store
there are too many options and you can't
tell the difference between any of them
it's a brush or is this for my taint why
is it always go to the taint I don't
know then if you have any questions the
clerk usually doesn't know the
difference either or I can't really help
you since they are not an expert on the
products or maybe they just have one
person working there like my experience
in [ __ ] CVS and Duane Reade they run
a skeleton shift in the middle of the
[ __ ] day now you don't have to step
foot in a store to get high quality to
get a high quality shave and grooming
products Dollar Shave Club delivers them
right to your door pube trimmers there's
something else this is like the family
feud name something you'd find in a
bathroom Johnson family pube trimmers
show me puke primers that we like the
forth answer everybody collapse you know
and as they go like the authority and
the intelligence slowly starts to drop
you know maybe if they have an artist in
the family that last family members are
right but when they get down to that
last person who else do we [ __ ] and
bring you know anyways where am I ask
for a limited time Dollar Shave Club is
basically giving away their [ __ ] shower
shave starter set to new members for
only five dollars this starter set
features the executive razor and three
trial size versions of their most
popular products that help you stay
fresh and clean so fresh and so clean in
your first box you will receive their
shave butter body wash and one wipe
Charlies oh sorry butt wipes one wipe
Charlie butt wipes I've never used those
one wipe and you get it I don't know
about that I don't know about that you
will also receive even like the cocaine
shit's the coke shits I always hear
about cuz they've been cut with
laxatives that should be the test on the
commercial when they do the one white
butt shot one wipe Charlies butt shape
butt wipes I just I don't know why I
can't talk today you also receive their
executive razor which includes their
premium weighty handle and full cassette
of cartridges can I give you guys advice
on a safety razor when you have a
weighted handle do not pull it across
your face hold it lightly and let
gravity with the weight of the handle
bring it down across your face if you
don't you're gonna cut yourself you'll
also receive their executive razor which
includes IR just said that after the
first box replacement cartridges are
sent for only a few bucks a month this
offers exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's Dollar Shave Club
calm slash Burt Dollar Shave club's high
quality products will have you covered
from face cheeks to butt cheeks there's
no better time to try the club alright I
swear to god this is the last one and I
love stamps.com because they know I
can't read so they always make it nice
and quick stamps calm everybody stamps
save you time and money which you can
use to grow your business or stare at
your balls I can mail any letter and
package just using my computer and my
printer and the mailman comes and picks
it up she's actually a lady and she's
really offended avoid the hassle of the
post office and mail everything from the
postcards from postcards to envelopes to
packages domestic or international
create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and no
long-term commitments clink print mail
and you're done unlike the post office
stamps calm never closes write just like
the [ __ ] up the street it never the
[ __ ] legs up the street
stamps calm never closes print postage
for letters or packages at your
convenience 24/7 keyboards slash
descriptors convenient easy reliable and
flexible just like the [ __ ] of the
street I use stamps calm because include
your personal recommendation I had a
baby tooth left in my head and it
finally fell out and I use stamps calm
to mail it back to my mother when she
sent me a quarter and right now you two
can enjoy the stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
without long term commitments go to
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in BER
that stamps calm and tuber stamps calm
never go to the post office again
alright is that it is that it for the
reading what else did I want to talk
about that I handle everything I think I
did by the way I'm gonna be in st.
Petersburg Florida at the Mahaffey
theater they added a late show this
Friday night it's going to be me Rose
Bowl tailgate legend aka
the the crown royal kid joe Bartnik
that's his new nickname the crown royal
kid he just got signed to a three-year
deal paul virzi Paul dude I called it
burrs E whatever you do did not bring up
that his Giants are Owen for okay he's
very sensitive we're gonna be down there
and Thursday night I'm going to the
Patriots for his Tampa game I'm gonna be
respectful I'm not wearing my Patriots
gear cuz I don't listen everybody giving
me [ __ ] I don't need all that [ __ ] even
if we wanted to feed it I still wouldn't
wear it I've learned I just got just go
there I silently route from my [ __ ]
team of Tampa wins I say congratulations
who gives a [ __ ] this is the last NFL
team that I need to see a home game of
and then I'll have gone to all the
baseball and all the all the football at
a professional level and in my world of
doing horrible in school and going to
colleges a numerous colleges during my
college career none of which I went to
NC State for my first my freshman year
sort of was in the off-campus program I
literally [ __ ] drove into the library
and watched the classes on cassette tape
like I had some sort of [ __ ] terminal
disease that was my first semester in
second semester I had two classes both
of which I flunked because by then I
decided I didn't want to be in North
Carolina so I sort of went there this is
back when NC State Wolfpack had like
Chucky Brown and Charles I think it was
Charles Shackleford I believe they still
had grass seats in the endzone I went to
a Carolina State game there then I went
to a couple other schools ended up in a
Mersenne Emerson I don't even know what
I [ __ ] mascot is I have no idea what
it is anyways it's like a final draft
software or some [ __ ] the [ __ ] am I
talking about yes I'm gonna be in st.
Petersburg and then I'm gonna own on
Saturday we're going to the Florida
Gators first LSU mighty LSU so I will be
silently rooting for I like Florida too
but I'll be rooting for LSU man I can't
[ __ ]
just cuz they lost to the Sunbelt
Trojans the [ __ ] but I get to go to the
legendary swamp and I actually love both
those teams but I decided to hitch my
wagon to LSU so I can't just like [ __ ]
jump III you know I'm not gonna be a
Content on either one of those I'm just
gonna be happy to be at that legendary
field at the swamp and then also to be
at the Pirates of the Caribbean stadium
stadium that the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
playing all right Lewis Hamilton on HBO
hey Bill big fan just wanted to let you
know that Lewis Hamilton is going to be
featured on HBO's real sports tonight I
got to watch that if you miss it I'm
sure you can I'm sure you can watch it
later on demand keep doing your thing
love f is for family in the podcast is a
weekly ritual for me best switches to
you and your growing family oh thank you
very much I'm gonna try to check that
out I saw I follow Lewis Hamilton on
Twitter and I saw that he had some
announcement to make and it looked like
he was wearing some MotoGP suit he was
walking to towards a motorcycle now
there's no [ __ ] way
the Mercedes team is gonna let him do
that right I don't think so so I don't
know what the announcement was maybe it
said he got another diamond stud for his
other side to his nose I have no idea
I don't pretend to live in that man's
stratosphere I live in the troposphere
he lives in the stratosphere all right
the Buccaneers logo everybody Bullitt
built the original Buccaneers logo was
taking from the school I went to
Beloit College they settled in court and
Beloit won because the school has been
around before the NFL the school is big
in the liberal arts culture and the
conversation of changing the mascot due
to the barbaric history of the
Buccaneers the school actually has two
mascots an official and unofficial the
unofficial
is a turtle and they're trying to see if
they can make it the official mascot
over the Buccaneer good lord
I could I could give a [ __ ] about it but
how would you feel if the pay tree
were to change to a [ __ ] animal first
of all I [ __ ] love turtles if you
don't like turtles man there's something
wrong with you
they're awesome they don't bug anybody
and if you think they're [ __ ] go out
and go get bit by one
I [ __ ] love turtles I had one as a
pet I went to church and I came home and
it drowned his name was Ralph and I
buried it in the [ __ ] woods I never
got another one thanks for bringing it
up anyways some [ __ ] animal because
they're associated with white
nationalists or whatever grotesques
historical events that is beyond our
control the funny thing about that is
all the liberal white people that go
along with doing that [ __ ] do not want
to give up their land or their
flat-screen TVs I get you know so is a a
half-assed you know gesture they're
gonna get rid of the mascot like
obviously I feel the Redskins I mean
it's literally like a racial slur so I
get that one but this other [ __ ] I mean
I don't know liberal people want to get
rid of it but I feel that's kind of a
way of getting away with being [ __ ] is
you kind of getting rid of the evidence
you know if they have the Buccaneer on
the side they'll be like whoa who's that
and be like oh yeah that was a group of
white people that came over here and
just massacred a bunch of [ __ ] people
just took a bunch of [ __ ] they were evil
they were evil and for all I know you
are one of their descendants but if you
just make it all go away and there's
just a turtle I don't know I think they
give human beings too much credit like
you have to understand that we're kind
of out of our [ __ ] minds some of this
something some of it has to do with
power I don't know what it is but uh I
don't know we get too much power we
behave like those [ __ ] chimpanzees
when they go out and hunt other monkeys
you know I mean I'll never [ __ ] get
over watching that I just it's the human
the way they get excited and the way
they torture the other [ __ ] monkey
rather than just kill the [ __ ] thing
is is a level of like so dude that's why
I don't like cats I don't like how they
just won't kill the mouse how the
[ __ ] thing's freaking I just put it
out of its [ __ ] misery they want to
still want to have fun
that like if somebody said we're
descendants of cats I'd be like yeah I
[ __ ] believe that
we're always sneaking up on each other
trying to stab one another you know
anyways I respect cats though you know I
respect them all I'm just saying you
know that behavior is just [ __ ] weird
anyways he says love the [ __ ] out of the
podcast been listening since 2011 and
followed your comedy since why do I do
this thank you for all the laughs hope
your family's doing well go [ __ ]
yourself yeah my baby girl had a little
bit of the sniffles doing a baby as a
cold and it's sneezes this the funniest
[ __ ] ever they don't cover their mouth
and just it's [ __ ] unreal it's like
poltergeist and what's that what's that
Nickelodeon slimed so if you got a baby
somebody told me this is good advice was
just to get like a face cloth and have
it wet just you know dab at it so you
know make their nose all raw and all
that stuff obviously frequently rinse it
out change it I know this is disgusting
but it was kind of what I was doing I
feel like I gave her the cold because I
came back from Toronto and I felt like I
had was fighting off something and I'm
not gonna not hug and kiss my daughter
my daughter in there right so I was
hanging out with her and uh Nia was out
with some friends this weekend so it was
kind of uh I got to be the single dad
and I gotta tell you man I [ __ ] loved
it you know I don't know what these
single parents are complaining about I
did it for about eight hours and I
didn't have a problem at all no it was
awesome we watched him the Formula One
race for three and she watched the
Patriots game I got our Patriots onesie
I think it said little but awesome or
something like that has the Patriot logo
on it and whenever it's football Sunday
and what's cool is Nia is not into
sports and [ __ ] so she didn't want her
to have a bunch of sports [ __ ] but I've
just bought it anyways and she fought
for like two seconds he's like all right
if you're into that fine she gets it she
gets it so that's what it is football
Sunday I come home she's got two
different Patriots one sees I gotta get
her a Bruins one for the season coming
up
and all its playoff baseball Joe bucket
is finest efforts for families Joe Buck
at his finest looking forward to that
crossing my fingers for Yankees Red Sox
matchup
another classic series who knows who
wins this you know I don't know how many
times we played this year but we were
dead even you know if we played 18 times
we went 9 and 9 and I got it to be
interesting series because I haven't
seen price be able to beat the [ __ ]
Yankees at least in the second half when
I was paying attention so we'll see how
many home runs that judge end up with a
lot of the people who have given him
[ __ ] I was so happy that he got [ __ ]
50 at least [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I'm
telling you did they say that the home
run derby [ __ ] up your swing oh is
that what they say is that what they say
you know you're not a football Scout are
you alright Aaron judge all [ __ ] rise
Court is in session have you reached a
verdict we get it his last names judge
Aaron judge stats here we go I know he
got 50 what did he finish with all
months 50 [ __ ] toe holy [ __ ] that is
[ __ ] amazing 52 home runs I don't
nobody give him [ __ ] about his
strikeouts gives a [ __ ] 114 RBIs 127
base on balls 208 strikeouts 52 home
runs did 542 at-bats
and he hit two he still hit 284 with two
out two hundred and eight strikeouts
he's still at 284 it's [ __ ] amazing
what a season congratulations to him I
hope we beat you OPP if we [ __ ] you
know but I'm not you know I'm not one of
those [ __ ] that can't recognize
greatness that's [ __ ] amazing alright
dear Billy button-nose I thought this
was interesting a new French law says
that photos must come with a disclaimer
that they're photoshopped I love the
French I [ __ ] love the French you
know what I mean you know why because
they [ __ ] going around having
threesomes and they're sick of giving
excite
did about bringing somebody else into
their relationship and they don't look
like the [ __ ] picture you know what I
mean
I get it anyways it's being done to
discourage unhealthy extreme thinness
among people trying to emulate
unrealistic body shapes that were faked
with a computer program alright so I was
a little off the mark on that this could
really change the landscape for models
right there's a sports equivalent in
there somewhere
love you love Nia keep up the good work
yeah I mean I I think that's probably
that's not for adults that's for more I
think that's for kids because I noticed
you know when I went to Toronto I
couldn't believe how good-looking the
people were and I've just got been going
around in general just noticing how
good-looking people are I was just like
what the [ __ ] is going on and what I
think it is it's I think it's a result
of everybody being on social media and
you post a picture yourself and you know
all the stuff that you didn't like about
yourself and then [ __ ] that you didn't
even recognize that that evidently
people other people noticed in comments
you know a dude you [ __ ] nice new
profile picture but I got us I gotta ask
what's up with your right ear what's up
with that shirt what's up with the blah
blah blah you know and then it's unreal
and then you start getting like a
[ __ ] complex social media is other
than promoting or anyways I just feel
like for me social media I promote gigs
and I go on and I try to make people
laugh that's it but to actually go on
there and look at comments it's just not
a healthy thing I don't think it's
healthy for anybody even if you're the
most beautiful [ __ ] person in the
world because you know at some point
you're gonna start to go down the other
side and then the comments hey you're
still hot but you started to look
starting to show your age there lol just
kidding you know I love you that's all
somebody who's got nothing nothing but
[ __ ] compliments needs to hear and
then it's just a downward spiral into
[ __ ] Botox and all that [ __ ] if I
could promote anything
just [ __ ] just act you goddamn age
that's the best way to do it just as
you're in your 40s dressed like you're
in your 40s keep yourself in good
[ __ ] shape there's a certain number
you hit and the best you can be at that
point is you look good for your age and
if somebody says that's he it's a
[ __ ] compliment you got to be young
you weren't cheated all right stop
trying to [ __ ] hang on by your
fingernails it's [ __ ] over let young
people be young let them have this
whatever the [ __ ] it is they're doing
with those goddamn DJ's I don't get it
but it's their [ __ ] let them have it
stop showing up with your Botox face
asking if anybody has any Molly okay
you're creeping people out all right
it's over my public service announcement
is over all right
apocalypse prep hey Bill recently my
girlfriend got mad that I don't have
anything prepared in case of a hurricane
or a massive flood I'm not naive
but we live in Kansas City I told her
that while I have a flashlight extra
cases of water and a generator not bad
for a 25 year old homeowner that's
pretty [ __ ] great and you own a home
at 25 congratulations I don't have a box
titled apocalypse [ __ ] she said I never
think about the future oh boy
I told you no well you know at least
she's not asking for a kid weight mean I
don't think about the future I bought a
house you dizzy broad I told her that a
gas-powered generator is literally a
symbol for the future you talk about
this stuff all the time but have you
actually got anything ready
thanks PS love the music and the
throwbacks well thank Andrew themelis
he's the one who picks out the music I I
bought some [ __ ] I bought some bucket of
[ __ ] food that you know would last
forever and like the lid on the bucket
also doubled as a toilet seat you could
[ __ ] in the bucket but then I don't know
where your food went I went down the
rabbit hole you know about 10 years ago
thinking about you know going off the
grid and
[ __ ] buying gold and silver coins and
all of this [ __ ] and then I was just
then I just went the other way
and I was just like you know I don't
think I want to survive the apocalypse
I'm fine if I'm laying in the street you
don't I mean cuz then I would just live
this unbelievable quality life and then
once the apocalypse hit and everything
sucked
I wouldn't have to [ __ ] live through
it you know you like when a [ __ ]
player like say like Doc Rivers like you
know he won a championship with the
Celtics and then they totally dismantled
the team he's like dude I'm too [ __ ]
old to go through a rebuilding year
that's how I feel with like society okay
it's just been great every [ __ ] day
of my life okay
yeah I just you know my [ __ ] dresser
drawer is full of championship rings I
got to live in this country look at how
I looked I [ __ ] lucked out I'm not
gonna [ __ ] lie to you I lucked out so
follow that [ __ ] goes away you know what
I mean and everything just collapses and
then [ __ ] prisoners a crime I gotta
[ __ ] survive that so that'll be it
you know what I mean I'd [ __ ] down a
bottle of booze and then just turn the
study guess it's different now that I
got a family I don't know maybe I'll buy
a generator alright movie like movie
lines I gave you one this week see she
she dear Billy bass drum this is the
best line from a sub come on could we
talk bass drums here for a second
everybody I know has a different [ __ ]
way of tuning the goddamn bass drum what
is your what is the way that you do it
do you get a good sound out of it I just
had somebody blew my [ __ ] mind when I
thought it was you just tuned the the
batter head you know that was the one
that I thought you put a little tension
to and then I thought the other side you
just [ __ ] you know just you know
tightened it past the wrinkle all right
cuz hey you wanna think you want to move
that air right you also want to have
don't know [ __ ] the [ __ ] beater have
something to rebound off
and then I met somebody and he [ __ ]
tells me the exact opposite thing and
then I met somebody this weekend and he
goes back the other way I don't know
what the [ __ ] to do all I know is my
bass drum tuning sucks
so whatever I'm gonna give it another
shot I'm just gonna you just have to
have the balls to just just keep on
doing it and doing it back again and
they're just dealing with whatever [ __ ]
sound you come up with in each time
hopefully getting it a little bit better
but uh I'm always open to listen to
people any ideas you have please let me
know all right dear Billy bass drum this
is the best line from a supporting
character in a movie is from Wayne's
World 2
there's nothing vulgar so you can play
it on air Wayne and Garth had brought a
roadie back from the UK to help put a
concert put on a concert while hanging
out he tells them this crazy story
rock and roll story about Ozzy Jeff Beck
and Keith Richards give it a listen
all right let's hope there's no [ __ ]
racial slurs in this like there was last
week or some reason the link isn't
working why I want the link work where
is it oh you know what I have to go over
here hang on I'll hit pause you know the
torture your way through this alright
we're back here we go
here it is come on no one's gonna be
able to hear this dude I don't know why
it's super [ __ ] quiet what's going on
here I got all the volumes up oh I know
this thing and that's when he in the end
he said you know he goes into the store
to go buy and he would need to buy
chocolate M&Ms to fill up into Ozzy's
brandy glass and he goes there and the
place was closed and they had some dog
he fights off the dog and then he had
the murder the owners with their own
shoes right I think that's what it is
I'm sorry dude
I don't know if any bacon
there you go nasty business isn't it I
never watch I know I never saw Wayne
swirl those work when I started doing
stand-up so I [ __ ] missed out on it
it's too busy trying to get on stage oh
by the way the ticket link for the all
things comedy podcast festival is in
Phoenix is up at billboard.com for the
first time ever I am going to do a live
Monday morning podcast now the first
thing you asking yourself is like you're
gonna have a guest no are you gonna
address the crowd no I'm gonna go out
there I'm gonna get a bed and I'm just
gonna lay down and you guys a [ __ ]
sit there and watch it I don't know if
it's gonna work but we'll see we'll see
it's gonna be more like a play it's
gonna have headphones on I'm gonna block
out people laughing I'm probably I have
to react to the crowd but I'm not gonna
be [ __ ] going out there doing
stand-up or any that I'm gonna sit down
and I'm just gonna [ __ ] and do my part
you know if you're just gonna be able to
watch it I gotta have some sort of
commemorative t-shirt or a poster some
[ __ ] but that is going down in Phoenix
Arizona see I've never done the video
thing I did it one time at the all
things comedy podcast I guess I did it
one time but if you ever wanted to see
what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] looks like who
knows maybe it won't work like rap like
rap life remember one day no I'm sorry
rap with a live band remember that when
they tried to do that unplugged the only
guy who ever pulled it off was LL Cool J
he pulled it off everybody else it just
never it just didn't [ __ ] work you
got ad
on the turntables I'm probably wrong
about that but I just said it and I'm
gonna stick by it
all right fat phobic dear Billy
backbreaker I'm a 28 year old white male
living in Ohio I had been single for
nearly four years now congratulations I
consider myself to be an active guy rock
climbing going to the gym is this like
your tinder [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
sending me I like to rock climb go to
the gym cycling etc anyways I used to be
overweight at 250 pounds and over the
course of a year I was able to get down
172 pounds and maintain that due to the
activeness and eating a plant-based diet
good for [ __ ] you sir
making me [ __ ] you're inspiring me good
for you man what a great thing you did
my situation is this I have some ladies
that have expressed their interest in me
however the majority of them are
overweight and have no self-control when
it comes to their diet and exercise I'm
not attracted to bigger women which puts
me in a difficult situation when they
very openly flirt and invite me out why
you're not attracted to them that's
totally fine and it's totally fine to
not be into overweight people I don't
know why you have to pretend that you're
into people that you're not into so the
person you know eating the [ __ ]
drakes cake can feel good about
themselves what about you there's still
a victim in there okay and considering
being on a shape is curable for most
people I'm not saying it's not a disease
but for most people they do what you do
plant-based diet they get active and it
[ __ ] falls off plus considering you
are a fatty this is like an alcoholic
you know who got sober you're gonna go
hang out with an alcoholic I guarantee
you'll become a fat [ __ ] hanging out
with them right and then where you're
gonna be you're gonna be laying down and
she tries to ride you on top I hope you
got enough to [ __ ] still get it in
there you do belly slapping together you
don't be part of that do you the ladies
can turn down men no problem but when a
man turns down a lady some of the ladies
I work with in their close friends I've
known
some of the ladies I work with and our
close friends I've known for years well
why the [ __ ] would you date them anyways
they know that I've been single for four
years honestly I am picky and I've also
learned to be happy after multiple bad
relationships dude you are [ __ ]
crushing life right now don't [ __ ] it up
by dating some fatty that you work with
because society is telling you that
you're not progressive
if you don't anyway so when I deny a
date request or don't flirt back with
them they say that I'm fat phobic is
this what this has come to like if some
fat [ __ ] mantid douche came walking
up to them pressing his dick up against
I mean that's what the [ __ ] they're
doing to you sticking their [ __ ] clam
in your face smelling like a Jim Dandy
Sunday at Friendly's right then what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] off I'm not fat phobic I just
weigh 172 pounds and I know that I can
get a better [ __ ] cut of meat I'm
sorry I didn't mean to go that mean I'm
just saying cuz that fat phobic pissed
me off alright you should respect
everybody just say listen I used to be
fat like you and I started rock climbing
why don't you rock climb okay or at
least maybe just stare at a bunch of
rocks instead eating rocky road ice
cream every [ __ ] weekend maybe yeah
I'll throw you a bang every once in a
while as dice clay says I'll trow you a
bang yeah dude can I tell you something
right now
this [ __ ] woman's movement thing is
completely out of control
it's completely out of control they are
not all of them but so many of them are
everything that they're [ __ ]
preaching that they don't want guys to
do to them
okay they're you know you have the
absolute 100% right to date whoever the
[ __ ] you want to date you have the right
to be as shallow as you [ __ ] wanna be
you can date full looks for 10 [ __ ]
years if you want to before you want to
settle down and get serious you know and
if you wait too long you're
gonna pay the price but it's your life
don't let it this is this is your
[ __ ] life dude you're gonna date some
[ __ ] fatty and you don't want to just
so what that those constant work will
look at you in a better way I I wouldn't
do that just be like yeah my dance card
is full all right this is these are the
measurements I like and I'm not ashamed
of it okay that's what I find attractive
as do you can I tell you something all
of those women at work if they could be
the size that you find attractive would
be you don't mean and they ate their way
into that position it's their job to eat
their way out the same way you did so
you had to get on a bike you had to
climb a bunch of rocks you had to do all
this [ __ ] now you're you're in game
shape right you're [ __ ] in Kobe
Bryant shape and they're showing up like
Shaq and they want to try to play their
way into shape remember Kobe's don't
skip chef [ __ ] for doing that yeah [ __ ]
that anyways he says I've never pointed
out their weight but when I have openly
expressed interest in other women while
talking to the other guys at work that
women start to shame me all right dude
you know what I was on your side until
you said shame what what the [ __ ]
happened him what happened to people
they shame you you just [ __ ] laugh at
him saying that I only like bones and
twigs I get along with everybody so I
never strike back well that's your
problem with anything in fear that I
might be taken to HR for God knows what
in days also having denied some of the
women they've gone as far as to not
speak to me as much and tell other
female co-workers how horrible of a man
I am leaving them to have bad attitudes
against me just because I won't date
them dude what do you look like Burt
Reynolds what the [ __ ] going on here I
would yeah listen this is the deal women
go to HR guys just laugh at it so just
laugh at it dude you know what I would
do I would be overly friendly to the
ones that hate me you know
morning sue you look lovely today kill
them with kindness and then I would
bring the most smokin hot [ __ ] chick
you could find to the [ __ ] Christmas
party that's what you got to do anyways
he says it's true I'm not attracted to
bigger women that's fine
there's nothing wrong with that but
women sit around all day talking about
guys having to be this tall have this
facial hair wear these clothes but when
a man has any sort of criteria we get
shamed dude stop saying that okay being
shamed is totally within your own power
at the age that you're at okay if you're
a [ __ ] teenager or younger I get it
all right but at some point you got to
be comfortable with how you look okay
you got to get comfortable with yourself
and then someone can't shame you unless
you actually did something shameful yeah
if you kick the puppy across the room
you don't I mean you don't to be
comfortable enough with yourself that
you can handle the criticism and have it
not affect you you should feel shame
alright anyways because I'm writing to
hopefully get your take on the matter
and hear what you would do in this
situation I will never see desiring a
fit healthy person who cares about their
body has a bad thing no you shouldn't
and that's something that all people
should aspire to be fit and in shape
healthier than they were yesterday as
much as you can you know obviously the
aging process you're getting older every
second one step closer to the grave
right but you know in the meantime yeah
thanks for all the good laughs you Nia
are the friends I wish I had in real
life that's so nice have a good day and
go [ __ ] yourself yeah do it by the way
that goes for women too
those two women too all right
yeah date what the [ __ ] you want a date
and if you want to be shallow you know
and dish date hot people then just do
that see what that's like it's up to you
I don't understand you know what I mean
like the you know what you have at work
dude you have a bunch of busy bodies you
know and there's these people out there
that want to be the person to say I
introduced this person or that person
I'll dude I swear to god man I swear to
God you find the hottest [ __ ] chick
you can [ __ ] find you could [ __ ]
find take her to the goddamn Christmas
party and by the way let her know what's
up let her know what's up
I would I would fight I would tell some
[ __ ] I would tell some hot chick that
whole [ __ ] story and you know hot
chicks love being hot nothing that they
would make them feel hotter than to go
down there and have a bunch of women
look at her and just hate her because
how [ __ ] hot she is
there you go find that chick maybe she's
into sports too next thing you know you
guys are running the country not the
country the company that's perfect oh
it's a fantasy but maybe you can make it
happen sir good luck to you
good luck to you and that's it and by
the way there's plenty of guys out there
that like big women you know what I mean
it's plenty you get it's up to you to be
happy with your own [ __ ] body
alright I'm telling you telling you just
[ __ ] have a salad have one [ __ ]
salad a day start [ __ ] working out
read up as much as you can on nutrition
try the best you can do best fold you
can which is really difficult you know
so you could do then other than that
leave people alone and let them date who
the [ __ ] they want a date
alright that is the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll give you my [ __ ] pick of the
week on Thursday that's it when I'm in
Tampa I bump up a Thursday Night
Football oh god they're gonna be wearing
those ugly
under root [ __ ] jerseys whether they
call them the full court press jerseys
whatever the [ __ ] they call them all
right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves I'll
check in on you on Thursday